but once again we say once again in this
country the details of a senseless
tragedy yet another mass shooting this
time at a mall outside of Dallas Texas
Witnesses describe a horrific scene the
result of an AR-15 style rifle eight
people dead seven others injured we
don't know the motive as of yet but law
enforcement sources say the gunman may
have had links to a Neo-Nazi group we
are also still learning about the
victims one of them is a 20 year old
Christian lacour he was working as a
security guard at this mall Omar via
Franca has made his way there in Allen
Texas and we do warn you some of the
images in his report are disturbing Omar
good morning
good morning the memorial behind me
continues to grow as more people come
forward to pay their respects it's a
common scene at mass shootings Across
America and so is this sentiment of the
residents they all thought it could
never happen here
our community has just been hit
and it hurts
100 showed up for a solemn Sunday
Gathering
singing
[Applause]
remember the people killed in the latest
mass shooting
dozens of shots rang out at the busy
Allen Premium Outlets mall Saturday
afternoon
As Shoppers sprinted to safety I've got
victims we need an angel the gunman seen
here in dash cam video we've Frozen
fired dozens of rounds at customers
outside the stores it was Non-Stop and
there was nothing we could do police say
an officer who was at the mall for an
unrelated call confronted and killed the
gunman he heard gunshots located The
Gunshot located the shooter neutralized
the shooter
law enforcement sources tell CBS News
the shooter was wearing body armor and
was heavily armed with an AR style rifle
with dozens of rounds of ammunition just
pop up that's all you hear Amber told me
said she sheltered more than 60 people
inside her store during the attack you
never expect it so to be involved in it
is just another thing that just is
nothing you can explain well I saw
people running from the mall and I'm
like well this ain't good Stephen
spainhauer raced to the scene after
receiving a call from his son who was
working at one of the stores I started
counting bodies I counted seven Spain
Howard said he arrived before police got
to the mall and started looking for
survivors a little boy is just soaked
with blood from head to toe called out
from under one of the victims and
started walking around saying my mama's
hurt over and over and over so I grabbed
him and put him around the corner so he
could get him out of the area of trauma
you went across three people who were
dead yes until you found somebody who
was alive yes
did you find out anything about that
little boy I still don't know what
happened to him I would like to think he
is okay but I
it was
it was a little tough the Army veteran
says this scene was horrific it was a
war zone there there's no way these
people could have survived the assault
of those weapons
two sources tell CBS news that the
shooter had a patch on his clothing that
said rwds and they believe that stands
for right wing death squad associated
with extremists and right-wing Neo-Nazi
groups but investigators also say that
they're trying to see if he may have
been associated with the cartel or
prison gangs Gail
Omar thank you I mean I don't know how
many times we have to tell this story I
think we all need to stop saying it
could never happen here I think I'm
surprised people still do I feel the
psychic weight of it possibly happening
just about everywhere in this country
yeah and speaking of that one is immune
I don't want to perpetuate this feeling
that's settling in The Souls of this
nation but
this is another place that we add to the
list that you you might be afraid to go
to along with movie theaters and
churches and malls and schools college
campuses hospitals
churches yeah but we can't get
desensitized to it we can't we have to
keep talking about it we have to kill
change happens
and that's the question what will it
take for change that is a question I ask
all the time